Cloud skill games assured OSS and a new
Cadence for ciso perspectives if you
want to practice your Cloud skills in a
way that's anything but boring go ahead
and check out the arcade for Hands-On
learning digital Cloud Badges and even
Google Cloud swag assured open source
software service is now generally
available for Python and Java ecosystems
that means you can now incorporate the
same OSS packages that Google uses and
secures into your own workflows cloud
ciso perspectives are now publishing
twice a month check out the early April
Edition on the blog and be sure to
subscribe so you can see them right in
your inbox you can get more on all these
stories at the links below thanks for
watching this episode of Google Cloud
updates